Apple
keine Ahnung warum ich das jetzt gerade
mit so einem komischen Heil gesagt habe
Apple hat auf jeden Fall vor einigen
Tagen das neue iOS
16.4 Update rausgebracht und die Haupt
Änderung des Updates war dass man jetzt
besser telefonieren kann
man hört
Stimmen besser stimmen das Update
beinhaltete dann auf jeden Fall auch
noch so ein paar andere kleinere
Neuerungen wie beispielsweise das in der
Bücher App neuerdings die Seiten besser
umgeschlagen werden
das ist eine App die sollen das Seiten
so oder so waren jedoch mal
wieder die neuen emojis
[Musik]
also das waren die die jetzt davor die
emojis waren die da neu diese emojis
kamen vor einigen Monaten der bereits
mit dazu und ich bin ganz ehrlich ich
nutze die alle ich finde die sehr sehr
wild von daher war ich natürlich umso
gespannter auf die neuen emojis des
neuen iOS 1 Punkt 16 Punkt 13 Punkt 12
Punkt X von dem neuen Update und ich
wurde gnadenlos enttäuscht
und warum sage ich euch jetzt das hier
ist das erste emoji das hinzugefügt
wurde
das hier ist das nächste emoji das
hinzugefügt wurde da frage ich mich
einfach nur dicker dieses iPhone gibt es
seit keine Ahnung wie viel Jahren und
ihr kommt jetzt 2023 auf die Ideen
wlan-symbolen hinzuzufügen gut nach
Hause
noch ein paar mehr hinzugefügt ne zum
Beispiel neue Tiere
wieso sieht das so aus als würde dieser
Vogel gerade den übelsten Durchfall
Schiss vorbereiten es wurden allerdings
auch noch vier weitere Tiere hinzugefügt
und zwar eine Qualle
ich habe noch nie so eine wunderschöne
Qualle gesehen aber okay dann auch noch
eine ganz
echt ich verstehe generell nicht warum
man solche Tiere nicht schon vorher
gedacht hat weil es gab sogar Einhörner
die gibt es nicht mal Apple allerdings
zugeben muss ist dass ich den ganz emoji
wirklich ganz schön finde
auf jeden Fall noch weitere Tiere
zugefügt und zwar beispielsweise auch
ein Elch
die
Wasser keine Ahnung ob man dieses Ding
da geweint oder ob das zweite Ohren sind
oder so aber die sehen auf jeden Fall ob
sie so spaghetti-kellen
letztes Ziel war es dann auf jeden Fall
noch hinzugefügt wurde war Sandra Esel
versteht ihr weil Sandra dann wird auf
jeden Fall auch noch neue emoji
hinzugefügt wo ich mir einfach direkt
dachte Basti GHG bist du
denn es ist ein Flügel
aber nur ein Flügel auf der rechten
Seite
also warum spiegelt ihr den nicht das
wird doch viel geiler dann könnte man
jedem emoji einfach so Flügel geben
aber alles zu seiner Zeit wir machen
weiter mit den Herzen ich finde es gibt
genügend Herzen
ich ganz ehrlich bald haben die ganzen
influencerinnen und Beauty Mädels noch
mehr Herzen die sie bei ihren Followern
die sich ja so lieben mit reinpacken
können denn die neuen Herzen ich will
natürlich
gedacht es ist an der Zeit für neue
Herzen
himmelblau
grau
und das 20 pinke Herz
was ist euer Go2 Herz
nojoke von allen Herzen die es gibt im
iPhone ich blende euch hier noch mal ein
was ist das Herz was ihr am meisten
benutzt ihr unten in die Kommentare
kommen wir nun allerdings meine Damen
und Herren zum einzig und alleinigen
Gesichts emoji der im iOS 18/13 16.4
Update hinzugefügt wurde denn haltet
euch fest es ist der shaky head
und den finde ich ehrlich gesagt gar
nicht so schlecht
also da bin ich wirklich ehrlich den
finde ich gut den habe ich auch schon
ein paar mal benutzt
und der ist das das ist der einzige
emoji tatsächlich von den ganzen neuen
den ich wirklich nicht schlecht finde
wir warten immer noch auf seinem Papa
und nein das hier ist kein Alpaka das
ist ein Lama und ja ich muss furzen
ja ich habe glaube ich mir gerade in die
Hose geschissen das war's allerdings
noch nicht mit den neuen emojis die
Apple im Rahmen des 13.10
Update hinzugefügt hat denn es kommen
noch sieben weitere fangen wir direkt an
mit dieser Blume
es sieht irgendwie so aus hätte diese
Blumen allergische Reaktion ihr könnt
mir ja gerne unten in die Kommentare
schreiben was das für eine Blume ist es
juckt mich aber auch nicht machen wir
nun weiter mit zwei Lebensmitteln die
man tatsächlich über die Nahrung oder
einfach auch so direkt das allerdings
macht ist zu sich nehmen kann
[Musik]
Ingwer
diese Leute die egal was du hast die
sagen irgendwas erkältet Ingwer das
Halsschmerzen Ingwer Arm gebrochen
Ingwer drauf also
irgendjemand von euch ja so homöopo
homöope oh oh
super heilfrucht Gemüse oh was ist der
unterschied
Obst und Gemüse okay aber was Frucht
Englisch because I am smart and
ich bin ja gar kein Auto eigentlich
Smart zweites Lebensmittel ist auf jeden
Fall auch in Zukunft wurde waren
oh mein Gott vergessen die Erbsen bin
ich aber ganz ehrlich sehen ich will das
hier sehen und die sehen also generell
emojis sind sehr gut gemacht aber dieser
Erbsen emoji sieht sehr wild aus dann
meine Damen und Herren wurde tatsächlich
jemand von euch der sich gerade dieses
Video anschaut hinzugefügt ein Fan hier
steht ihr wegen Fan und Fan weil ihr
seid ja logischerweise alle Fans von mir
Danke Danke spaß beiseite meine Damen
und Herren schauen wir uns jetzt noch
mal im Schnelldurchlauf die letzten drei
emojis an die Apple im 13
13.13,13 Update warum sind da so Punkte
hinter eigentlich warum 16.4 warum nennt
sich nicht einfach 17
wäre doch viel schöner die haben auch
einfach aufgefallen bei den iPhones die
haben iPhone 3G 4G 5 geht dann kann
iPhone 6 7 8 dann kam 10
einfach übersprungen also wirklich
[Musik]
die letzten drei emojis die hinzugefügt
wurden wir haben einen Kamm
aber das ist auch so ein korrupter kam
irgendwie
wie heißen die Dinger diese komischen
Dinger wurden auf jeden Fall auch
hinzugefügt und kommen wir nun
zuletzten Sache die dieses iPad ich muss
schon wieder furzen
oder klarinette
hatte Deus nicht immer die Klarinette
allerdings würde ich an der Stelle das
heutige Video jetzt auch beenden meine
Damen und Herren ich bin noch immer sehr
enttäuscht über die Tatsache dass das
Alpaka noch immer nicht hinzugefügt
wurde von Apple da hinten in Amerika ich
schicke euch meine Scheiße dann das SAN
franciscount ne liebe Grüße wenn euch
meine reaction auf die neuen emojis
gefallen hat dann lass doch gerne einen
Daumen hoch unter dem Video hier da
abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke um weitere Videos nichts
verpassen plus bitte unten in die
Kommentare schreiben welches Herz ihr am
ehesten oder am meisten oder generell
benutzt
vielleicht seid ihr auch herzlos
das wäre anatomisch aber ein bisschen
schlecht weil dann würde ich atmen